oh this was food i had in sochi this was
like a weird thing
it was a poached egg
on top of salmon
on top of avocado
on top of a waffle
on top of another waffle
almost on top of a tomato
[Music]
on top of a plate
on top of a table
on top of like the little outdoor
seating area that we were
eating at
anyway
it would be cool to just have like a
giant avocado as my green screen
let's move on let's play uno mas i'll
play
we'll do random sub so
uh good luck to
uh good luck to this person
let's play e4
oh pam with the leftover bits
oh opponents offline we might uh
might get a new opponent
or not okay
stafford gambit time
maybe this time i'll actually go into a
staffer now
and show how it's done
i'm actually curious if my opponent
has watched my most recent youtube video
[Music]
i guess we're about to find out
if you've seen the most recent youtube
video you you'll know what move fox
should play in this position
or if you've even seen the thumbnail
yeah this position is on my uh
most recent youtube thumbnail
wow
so now i'm encountering
i'm encountering the refutation to the
refutation
which i'm going to try and refute
g5
so okay so i know bishop e2 is not a
good move
because queen d4 castling g4
i nobody wants to do this stuff
so
in rows and face let's play b4
let's just make things even spicier
like sometimes when you add some
pepper
to your avocado toast or your eggs
then you just want to add some some
sriracha and then some hot sauce
some sambal
[Music]
just make things even more spicy
increase the flavor
so i was saying earlier how sometimes
pawns just get in the way of things
so this pawn was getting in the way of
my my rook
and my bishop
the rook wants to enjoy the file
bishop wants to enjoy the diagonal
especially because
these pieces are aligned and there's no
g pawn to support the knights
so opponent is probably just flustered
i feel like this is a novelty too
because this move is like super super
rare
only been played a few dozen times
okay so now it's a question do i do this
or this or this
i wanted to play this but after takes
takes takes
takes takes i'm just suffering
so
[Music]
let's play queen f3
staying flexible pressuring the knight
supporting this knight
if takes takes there's a pin
and then potential battery
whoa past pawn quadruple nine
gifting five
thank you passpon
again no pass pawns in this position
but maybe later
yeah and i still have the ideas of this
new haircut maybe this won't help your
game though
oh
i feel like that's a compliment and an
insult
but i feel like it could help my game
i have less hair to get in the way of my
ability to move pieces
wow g4
[Music]
there's a sad line takes takes queen f4
takes takes and then i get made it on d1
i think i'll play queen e3
just uh
safe square
still supporting the knight
leaving the tension between the pawns
maybe supporting e5 in the near future
the thing about this position
black's king has no safe place to go
it's not super safe in the center
casting of course is not safe with
my potential casting queen sidewalks
into my half open b file
yeah i'm ready ready to like complete
development
relatively naturally
yeah as black i would be a bit perplexed
here like what to do
i don't want to give back clues either
like i'm not gonna start suggesting
moves oh a5
a5 could be useful rook b1 no longer
actually
threatens to take the bishop
yeah let's play this
i might end up casting queen side and
then play d4 and just have a nice center
or i might go insane and eventually play
knight d5
like this is a move to consider further
down the road
or maybe even right now
because takes takes
no probably not right now
man what is this position
i think i'll play a3
it feels like a slow move but the bishop
doesn't really have a great option
[Music]
if it takes i take with queen and get
the battery
moves here i take it moves here i fork
moves here it's kind of sad
oh
okay so i could win the bishop right
away or i could fork
and potentially win more material
oh there's a funny line okay i'm gonna
take
so
first of all okay i'm pinning the the
thing to the thing
so black wants to regain the pawn
there's queen digs before but then after
bishop a3
this is almost trapping the queen
i'm preventing the queen from retreating
along the diagonal i'm controlling all
these squares
except
except b6
b6 is covered by the pawn
so if queen b6
i then played bishop
c5
again almost trapping the queen
the queen will have to move to b2 only
safe square
rook b1 almost trapping the queen
only say squares to take on c2
and then i think after bishop d3 the
queen is officially trapped
on c2
[Music]
i hope i'm not missing anything but i'm
pretty sure this is the case
there's a question what i'm drinking
from
it's from this uh fide branded world cup
thermist type thing
and the cover to it
also acts as a cup
so it's kind of a cool
contraption
but not as cool as this
tactical sequence
to trap black's queen
yeah the pieces really work together
here so the bishops control squares
the rook's going to come in
the knight
serves
light actually like serves a very good
purpose
controlling a2 and b1
and there's no
real way for black to effectively
counter attack
that queen is pretty safe king is very
safe
okay so we're going into like the whole
line i
i was just mentioning
yeah it's important that bishop covers
a3
and okay oh no black's queen
and conveniently i take
with the knight on b1
to set up for the next game
i realized the other day that a really
nice benefit to online chess is you
don't really need to set up the pieces
after every game
like when you play over the board
usually when you end the game you reset
the board
but online it's easy to be so spoiled
let's play this move
attacking the knight
oh i'm getting forked oh
no ah
checkmate
okay
i think that's a nice way to end the
stream
and probably end the future youtube
video hope you enjoy that if you're
watching in the future on youtube
be sure to subscribe
and
bye merch